Thank you.
I have a couple notes for these bills that are in the clerk's office, and we are arranging to get them delivered.
And next Tuesday, the House Committee Services is having a going-away due for Heather at the Upham Walker House, and we are all invited.
So, if you interested in attending, please do.
Anything else?
Okay, in that case, I'm going to open the I represent Hillsboro 39 which is Ward 6 8 and 9 in Manchester hospital 250 FN is just a very simple bill.
It's just going from 50% to 100% of the annual earned compensation for the death benefit for a firefighter.
You might think that's a big jump, but it's not.
This is only catching up.
Right now, if I was a firefighter and I retired, I'd get 100% of my benefit.
But if I got killed in a line of duty, my spouse or my family would only get 50%.
So they're penalizing me 50% for working and getting killed in a line of duty.
This is only a fairness thing, and I just think it's pretty simple and straightforward.
I think that's about enough to say.
It's a fairness thing.
I'll take any questions.
Thank Broody I don't see that this is necessarily line of duty death isn't it all accidental deaths while in service well in service right well they're like if they're on there If someone were to be on vacation and got killed in an automobile accident they would still get this benefit correct well they should yeah okay thank you i just want to be clear other questions all right don't see any others thank you very much okay thank you and i'd like to call mark kavanaugh from the retirement system Thank you very much.
Okay.
Thank you.
And I'd like to call Mark Cavanaugh from the Retirement System.
Thank you, Madam Chair.
My name is Mark Cavanaugh.
I'm Associate Counsel and Compliance Officer for the New Hampshire Retirement System.
I'd like to start just by clarifying what you just mentioned.
Accidental is a term of art under our statute.
It means a work-related death, not just an accident in a generic sense.
So yes, this bill is limited to people who die due to an accident at work while working.
Requires a finding of compensability by the Workers' Comp Bureau before we can award our benefit.
Okay, thank you.
Is there a death benefit for someone who dies?
Yes, that's called ordinary death.
If you have 10 years of service, you're a suspect of 50% annuity.
Of course, if you're very young, that gets discounted.
Or the option, if you don't have a spouse or if your spouse doesn't want to take the annuity, you get a return of your contribution account plus interest and one year's salary or one year's compensation as reported to us that's based the ordinary death is based on average final compensation accidental death for group two is based on the annual rate of compensation it's basically the same except we would not apply those limits on final year salary like the hundred and fifty percent rule the limit on compensation over base the limit on special duty that would apply in a normal service retirement those don't apply in the case of a group to accidental death it's merely the the annuity is based on whatever had been reported to us for the prior 12 months This benefit would this bill would increase that from a 50% of that amount to 100% of that amount I'd also like to say there are 26 people currently collecting this benefit.
It's not a huge population There are 19 Widowers widows or widowers of firefighters and seven police.
Thank you for that data.
That's very helpful.
Representative Schmidt and then Representative Dolan.
Thank you very much, Madam Chair.
Good morning, Mark.
So you've been at this game for long enough.
You may remember when the death benefit was first under discussion before the legislature, something in the neighborhood of 16 years ago, I think.
And we looked at the cost of an insurance program and so forth.
And we ultimately, we, the legislature, ultimately determined that we would be better off in terms of the probability of this benefit ever being collected.
We'd be better off by funding it out of the general fund in the instance in which it would occur.
So I'm wondering whether, because you're here to give us advice on the niceties and technicalities of the bill and of the situation.
So it looks like this benefit would come out of the retirement system, unlike the death benefit that we said for police officers and I think firefighters that we put into statute early days, we've subsequently kind of incrementally expanded that to a wider population because it's still a very infrequent event.
As you know, just last, I think, previous term, not last term, that this was going to be for our people who are working for the Department of Transportation, because many of them are doing hazardous things every time I drive along in the summertime, and seeing them mowing along and they're running their mower along on an angle like this, I'm thinking, what is keeping Dr.
Dr.
Newton, Isaac Newton, from pulling this person off that thing with a fatal outcome?
But anyway, they are very often very hazard oriented.
Yes, Representative Schmidt, And your question?
Well, the question is, we've expanded it, but would the benefit, if payable, come out of the retirement system in this instance?
Yes, this would be a benefit payable out of the funds of the retirement system.
And the estimated increased cost of this bill is 1.3 million dollars that would have some downstream effect on employer rates very very low uh so low that we didn't bother to ask the actuary because it's de minimis in the scheme of our total assets but there is a little bit of a cost associated, comes out of our system.
Thank you.
That additional clarification is really helpful.
Yes.
Representative Dolan.
Yes, thank you, Madam Chair.
Thank you for taking, presenting your testimony.
A question I have for our firefighters, for example, very easy to understand if they're fighting a fire and the house caves in on them and they die from that, that that's an accidental death.
How would you extend this benefit to, let's say, firefighters that use that firefighting foam that we know in the long term can have cancer causing results.
Is that an accidental death or is that something else?
Well, I'd like to use just for clarity, say work related, you know, so we don't have to focus just on accidental.
The reason the word accidental is in there is historical because because our system paralleled workers' comp at a time years ago when something was compensable if you were hurt due to a particular accident that happened at work at a particular time.
Since then, causation has been expanded to occupational injuries due to repetitive motion over time, occupational illnesses due to repetitive motion over time, occupational illnesses due to exposure to hazardous chemicals and the like.
We follow the determination of workers' comp.
We don't make an individual evaluation as to whether something is work-related or not.
If workers' comp has issued a finding of compensability, then that is binding on us.
And we recently had a case of a fire chief who was accidental death due to colon cancer.
So yes, it's in the realm, but the determination is primarily made by workers' compensation.
Thank you, Madam Chair.
I believe that in the case of firefighters, there's a statutory definition that cancer is work-related.
There are certain presumptions under workers' comp law that apply to cancers and lung disease.
But again, we don't do that part of it.
We follow the lead of workers comp and the labor board thanks okay representative lacus thank you i'm just trying to understand the fiscal note so uh would this have any impact on the people that are currently collecting this annuity due to a prior accidental death, or is this all going to work?
No.
We read the statute as applying to deaths that occur after its effective date, and not a retroactive increase in benefits for those currently receiving one.
Thank you.
Okay.
Other questions?
Yes, Representative Bailey.
Thank you.
I perhaps don't know what I'm talking about, but the way group 2 was explained to me was that it was a pension, and then if the person being pensioned died, the survivor would get 50 percent.
Well, this would apply to persons who have not retired yet and die while active.
So the benefit is that if you have a spouse, minor children, or dependent parents, in that order, they're entitled to this annuity benefit.
They also, as I say, they also get a return his contributions.
So this benefit is fully funded by the state annuity fund.
We don't use the member contributions and interest from their member account to fund this benefit.
So in addition to this annuity, the spouse or the designated beneficiary would get a return of any accumulated contributions plus interest.
Follow-up?
Follow-up.
So if I was in this group two and died, the day after I retired, my spouse would get 50%.
It might take a little longer to process, but yeah.
If I died in the line of duty or something, my spouse would get 100%.
Correct.
And're and it doesn't say like it's gonna age out or anything it's no permanent it's for the rest of your life yeah the spouse so we'll have group two a and b um no it wouldn't change the groups it would just change the level of benefit based on when the death occurred before after the effective date of this statute thank you okay other uh representative true thank you madam chair and thank you for taking my question i'll go along with i don't know what i'm talking about and that's why i'm here you're saying it's going to cost like about a million dollars um who's paying for that?
Well, it's $1.3 million at the local level and $320 at the state level.
That is what the downstream increase in contributions would be due to having to fund the higher benefit.
So there is no cost for 24 and 25 because we can't increase those rates.
They've already been set.
So the first time we can increase the rates would be in 26.
And that's the annual cost going forward of funding the benefit, the increase in the benefit of 1.3 million and 320,000 at the state level.
Just like any increase in benefits, it can be terminally funded by an appropriation upfront of the present value of the future cost of that increase.
increase or if it is not terminally funded then downstream those increased liabilities are going to be reflected in the the employer contribution rates follow up thank you thank you madam chair so the downstream or the local cost is for local government not not for the employees.
Correct.
Contribution rates for members, employees, are fixed under statute.
So if there's increased costs that affect contributions, it's going to affect the employer contributions.
Thank you.
Other questions?
Thank you, Madam Chair.
You used a term that those of us who have been here for a while are familiar with, but the new people may not know what it means to say terminally funded.
Could you speak to that?
Terminally funded would be an appropriation from general funds to put up front and give to us the amount of money that would cover the future cost of the increase in benefits.
So instead of there being a downstream increase in contributions, we'd get the money up front.
And that's how sometimes coal is funded that way.
Particularly, we'll talk about that one later today.
Thank you.
Other questions?
All right.
one later today thank you other questions all right seeing none thank you mr cavanaugh you're welcome and uh brian rill Good morning, Madam Chair, members of the committee.
For the record, my name is Brian Rill.
I serve as the president of the Professional Firefighters of New Hampshire.
We represent approximately 2,000 active and retired firefighters, paramedics, and dispatchers throughout the Granite State.
On behalf of the firefighters, we advocate for the health and safety of our members.
And I just want to draw to your attention that just four miles from here where we sit today, on the grounds of the New Hampshire Fire Academy, there are four stone tablets with 92 names carved into them.
Those 92 names are those that made the ultimate sacrifice for the citizens of this state.
These heroes are remembered fondly every day by their family and their friends and they're honored every day by the firefighters that continue to get on the trucks and answer the call.
These are the very same firefighters who have to make it their duty to take care of the families of those that have fallen.
These families that are left in the in a wake of a disaster so unimaginable that it turns their lives upside down are trying to mourn the loss of their loved one while also trying to figure out how to pay their mortgage, put gas in their car, buy groceries.
They're the very same families who supported their loved ones as they protected the citizens of this state.
Through many countless nights, weekends, and holidays, many times 24, 48 hours at a time, these families lay awake at night wondering if they'll ever see their loved one again.
And we have 92 families that never saw their loved one again.
This is a very small change that was mentioned by those before me, and I think it's a fair change at that.
We can no longer sit back and allow the families of our fallen brothers and sisters to collect a mere 50 of their salary their compensation we ask that the committee fully support this small change and honor those that we've lost along the way i would be happy to entertain any questions you may have, Madam Chair.
Thank you, Mr.
Rill.
Are there questions?
All right.
Seek done.
Thank you very much.
Does anyone else wish to testify on House Bill 250?
Mr.
Beaudry.
All right.
I've got a stack of them i'll look for it Yes, sir.
Okay, thank you.
Madam Chairman, members of the committee, for the record, my name is Arthur Beaudry.
I am the president of the New Hampshire State Permanent Firefighters Retirement Association.
I am a retired captain from the Manchester Fire Department and a past trustee of the New Hampshire retirement system for 13 years.
I am here today in support of House Bill 250.
I have been addressing the legislature for over 40 years on retirement issues, and it wasn't until last year when working on the ordinary death benefit that it was brought to our attention that the accidental death benefit annuity was only 50% of the deceased member's annual rate of earnable compensation.
Under the ordinary death benefit language that passed last year, a member can sign a pre-option form, and if they have 20 years of service, their spouse can collect 100% of the member's annual rate of earnable compensation upon their death.
If a member gets injured in the line of duty and has to retire due to those injuries, that member would receive two-thirds of their annual rate of earnable compensation.
It only makes sense that if a member gives their ultimate sacrifice, their life, and the performance of their duty that their family should not be financially burdened by that loss.
It is tough enough to lose a loved one.
The least we can do is make sure that the family they leave behind doesn't have, also have to suffer financially.
I ask you please to support House Bill 250 and I will answer any questions.
Thank you.
Are there any questions?
Representative Schmidt.
Thank you, Madam Chair.
Good morning, Art.
It seems like you're reading from a prepared remark.
Can you provide that to the committee?
I can.
Thank you.
Thank you, Representative.
Other questions?
Thank you.
All right.
Seeing none, thank you for your testimony.
Does anyone else wish to testify?
all right seeing none i will I will close the hearing, and we have a few minutes before the next one.
Very good.
All right.
That's right.
You're going to talk on more of them.
No, sorry.
It was just buried under my stuff.
under my stuff.
Thank you.
Welcome back.
I'd like to mention that House Bill 250 is going to the Pension Subcommittee for further work and House Bill 571 will almost certainly go there as well i'm opening the hearing on house bill 571 and i'm calling representative berdy thank you madam chairman members of the committee i am still representative ben berruti from manchester representing hillsborough 39 manchester's Ward 6, 8, and 9.
I brought this forward because, again, I think it's time that some of these retired people catch up a little bit.
Over the last, see, group two people, when they retire, this is all they get for retirement income.
They don't get Social Security like most of the other people in this country yet, but this is all they have to live on.
So over the last 20 years, Social Security's gone up 64.5%.
And if you retired 20 years ago as a firefighter you got 15 percent increase during that time so you lose a lot of buying power and so this is a an attempt to get them a little something um i don't know if it'll mean a heck of a lot to them because the cost of living today, people who retired 20 years ago weren't getting much as it is, but not getting any increases.
They felt way, way behind.
And I think this is just an attempt to let them know that we'll try to let them catch up a little bit.
This is a two-phase thing.
You have to be retired 10 years to get an increase of 5%.
10 years.
Now, I don't know if anyone here has been retired and retired for 10 years, but just think of the additional income you got in the last 10 years from Social Security versus all we have for that 15% it's a big difference especially today the cost of living so I this is an attempt to do that there's no physical note on this this.
So I don't know how they're going to analyze it in the end.
That information is making its way to us.
We don't have it yet, but it's coming up.
Yeah.
So and that's basically it.
And it's only on the first 50,000.
Now, if if you retired 20 years ago, you're probably not even making $50,000.
So you would get your whole increase.
So that's what this bill does.
I hope the committee can support it.
Unlike the last bill, I don't know all the nuts and bolts about the numbers.
So to avoid any curveballs, I know there's people behind me that have a lot more, as far as statistics go, and numbers.
And maybe they can answer a lot more technical questions than I can.
I just brought this forward because I think it's the right thing to do.
Thank you, Representative Baruti.
Thank you.
And'll take any questions from anybody.
If I can answer, I'm fine.
If not...
I think you scared them all off.
Thank you.
Oh, no.
Now, Representative Dolan, go for it.
Thank you.
Thank you for taking my question.
Would this be funded out of local communities, or would this be funded out of the retirement fund?
I think this comes out of the general fund, out of the retirement general fund again.
Without specific funding from the general fund, any cost of living increases get folded into the future payments by the employers, which in the case of group two is almost entirely local police and fire.
Thank you.
Representative Gerhard.
Thank you, Madam Chair.
This is a one-time increase, or is this continual as far as the cost of living goes up?
No, no, once they get it, they'll continue getting it.
I'm saying, does this track to, Madam Chair, follow-up?
Follow-up, no, it doesn't track to inflation.
It's a one-time increase.
Yeah, it's a one-time increase.
Would it make more sense to just index this to inflation?
I think that would be better.
Yes, but it would cost a great deal more.
Yeah, and that's why we did it this way, because of the cost.
I mean, I would go along with it, but I don't know if the legislature would.
Well, I mean, inflation's going.
Exactly.
Representative Shewitt.
Thank you, Madam Chair.
Representative Rudy, is it not true that there was a one-time payment made in the last session to state employees, but the limit was, I believe, $30,000, so it kind of excluded?
I'm not sure of that.
I think they did get one.
I don't know when itION.
IT WAS LAST SESSION.
YES.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER?
NO?
VERY GOOD.
MR.
KAVANAUGH?
THANK YOU.
FOR THE RECORD, MARK KAVANAUGH, ASSOCIATE COUNSEL AND CO Counsel and Compliance Officer for the New Hampshire Retirement System.
A couple of clarifications.
This is a true COLA in that it is a permanent addition to the members' benefit going forward, as opposed to a temporary supplemental allowance, which is what happened last year.
It was a one-time payment.
It didn't get added to their benefit for the future.
It's a one-time calculation.
It's not a COLA every year, but once it's added to your benefit, it continues on.
It is also intended to be terminally funded from the general fund, And the of that would be 84.2 million dollars.
This is a benefit that's for the group two only who meet the criteria of 10 or 20 years of service.
There are 2100 group two retirees who have 10 years of service, and there are about 1600 who have 20 years of retirement, 20 years retired who will get the 10 percent COLA.
And again, 2100 who have 10 years retired who would get the 5% COLA.
Okay, thank you.
I'm hoping for questions.
Very good, well, Representative Lekas has one to get you started.
Thank you.
Maybe I'm probably missing it, but where in here does it indicate this would be funded from the general fund?
Lines 18 through 22.
Yes, thank you, Madam Chair.
Yeah.
Okay, great.
Thank you.
Representative Fitzpatrick.
Thank you, Madam Chair.
Has this been done in the past?
And if so, when was the last time?
uh last time we had a permanent edition cola such as this it's before i worked here and i'll be 10 years in April.
We've done the temporary one-time payments twice, three times in the last 10 years, but not even that many.
It's expensive, and so usually it doesn't pass the bar, so to speak.
Thank you, and thank you, Madam Chair.
Okay.
Other questions?
I just want to confirm you said that there are 2,100 people who would qualify for this benefit.
2,100 who would qualify for the 5%.
So people have at least 10 but less than 20 years being retired.
An additional 1,600 have more than 20 years since they retired and would qualify for the 10%.
Thank you.
at least 10 but less than 20 years being retired.
An additional 1,600 have more than 20 years since they retired and we qualify for the 10%.
Ah.
So.
Thank you.
So 3,700 altogether.
Okay.
Thank you.
That's good to know with the scope.
Anyone else?
Thank you.
That's good to know with the scope.
Anyone else?
Thank you.
Seeing no others, thank you very much.
Mr.
Rill.
Good morning, Madam Chair, members of the committee.
Once again, my name is Brian Rill.
I serve as the President of the Professional Firefighters of New Hampshire.
Professional Firefighters of New Hampshire is the state association that represents approximately 2,000 members and approximately 600 of those members are retirees.
I'm here before you today to ask you to support house bill 571 and it is important to understand both the role that our retirees have in the strength of the local economy and the foundation it provides for the long-term growth of our state continuous focus on stimulating the local economy is necessary and important for this legislature especially during uncertain times expenditures made by retirees provide a steady economic stimulus for new hampshire and one that cannot be overstated in 2020 the national institute of retirement security measured the economic impact of defined benefit pension expenditures and determined that the state and local pensions paid out $848.9 million in benefits, while retiree expenditures represented $1.4 billion in total economic output in New Hampshire.
So many state and municipal retirees dedicate their lives to a career in public service and contribute so much to our communities, yet many of them are forced to live in poverty.
In fact, 93% of our retirees make less than $50,000 a year, while federal poverty line in New Hampshire is just under $44,000.
The most jarring comparison is to that of the Consumer Price Index.
In the last 20 years, the total inflation calculated by the Bureau of Labor Statistics surpassed 52 percent while retired firefighters received a mere 13 and a half percent in cost of living adjustments this legislature has done so many great things over the years some of which have been to provide retirees with a temporary supplemental allowance, including last year's, in order to try and bridge the gap and provide them with financial relief.
However, Group 2 retirees often find themselves on the losing end of this deal.
Since they are not eligible for Social Security benefits, many of them narrowly exceed the limits for retirement allowance.
It's time for new hampshire to develop a sustainable cost of living adjustment for group two retirees that allow them to live long financially stable retirement and continue continue to contribute to our state's economy and i believe house bill 571 is that solution i would urge the committee's full support of this bill and i would entertain any questions you may have.
Thank you.
Are there questions?
And isn't it a feature of a defined benefit retirement system that the benefit is, in fact, defined?
And it doesn't increase?
Well, yes, I mean, I would say the benefit is in fact defined and it doesn't increase well yes I mean I would say the benefit would be defined but I would also think that it would be incumbent upon our state legislature to make sure that we don't have group two employees who are unable to survive financially I see thank you thank you other questions none.
Mr.
Beaudry.
Madam Chairman, members of the committee, again for the record, my name is Arthur Beaudry.
I am the president of the New Hampshire State Permanent Firefighters Retirement Association.
I am a retired captain of the Manchester Fire Department and a past trustee of the New Hampshire Retirement System for 13 years.
I am here today in support of House Bill 571, which would grant a COLA to retirees who have been retired for over 10 to 20 years.
For those of you who may not know the history of granting colas, here's a little background.
And some of you that have been on this committee have heard this before, but I think it's important to say it again.
Prior to the establishment of the special account in 1983 to fund cost of living adjustments, the cost of living cola was granted by the legislature and funded through the general fund from 1967 to 1983.
From 1983 to 2012, annual COLAs were granted based on the availability to fund them through the special account.
The COLA amount ranged from 1% to 5% based on the CPIU and funds available in each member's group account.
In 2007, House Bill 653 changed the funding trigger as of June 30, 2007 for the special account and retained $204 million in the corpus of the fund that would have gone to the special account.
In 2008, House Bill 1645 transferred $250 million from the special account to the corpus of the fund.
2011, House Bill 2 transferred $167 million from the special account to the corpus of the fund.
2012, House Bill 1483 eliminated the language for the special account and the remaining $16 million was transferred from the special account to the corpus of the fund.
The elimination of the special account and the transfer of $637 million from the special account to the corpus of the fund have precluded any future COLAs from being granted to the New Hampshire Retirement System retirees unless enabling legislation is enacted.
Retirees have received only one COLA since 2010.
So we did have one COLA.
Committeewoman Shewitt is the one that put that in.
It was a 1.5% cost of living adjustment based on your first $50,000.
Over the last decade, cost of living based on the CPIU has gone up by 29.33%, while COLA's granted to Group 2 Police and Fire over the same time period was 1.5%.
Over the last 20 years, cost of living has gone up by 64.53%, while COLAs granted the Group 2 police and fire over the same time period were 12.25% and 15%, respectively.
That is over 52% of a pensioner's buying power that has been eliminated due to inflation and the lack of adequate COLAs.
Last year, $500 stipend went predominantly to Group 1.
Out of the $11.6 million on the fiscal note, Group 1 received $10.75 million on that piece of legislation.
Over 92% of the $11.6 million went to Group 1.
Of the 23,267 eligible recipients, there were only 498 Group 2 fire receiving the stipend.
Social Security has given its members a 8.7% increase this year.
Unfortunately, Group 2 police and firefighters don't receive Social Security.
Under the Windfall Act of 1984, if a Group 2 member were to be eligible for Social Security, their benefits would be reduced by 40 percent at minimum and as much as 90 percent depending on their pension.
Predominantly, the New Hampshire retirement system is what Group 2 members rely on for their retirement income.
Very simple math will show you that in a matter of time without COLA adjustments, pensioners will be forced on some kind of social services based on their pensions will be devoured by inflation.
The average pension for Group 2 policemen and firefighters is $38,192 and $42,948, respectively.
There's a report developed by NASRA on cost of living adjustments that show how inflation impacts the purchase power.
A $25,000 pension falls to $16,690, 67% of its original value over a 20-year period with no cost of living adjustments based on a 2% inflation factor.
The natural brief also shows that New Hampshire is an anomaly.
Most states provide their retirees with a cost of living adjustment.
The state of Maine, for example, who came to testify at the request of the decennial committee, stated that they offer a 2.5% COLA to their retirees.
Massachusetts offers an ad hoc COLA typically based on the CPIU to 3%, applied to the first $13,000 of benefits.
Vermont offers an automatic COLA based on the CPIU up to 5% compounded.
Over the last several years, the legislature has arbitrarily taken funds away from retired workers that would have paid for COLAs and health care subsidies by changing dates and when excess earnings were reported and the elimination of the special account, some $637 million dedicated to retirees was diverted for no justifiable reason other than to lower the employer contributions on the backs of the retirees.
Granting a reasonable COLA for Group 2, retirees will greatly reduce the impact inflation has incurred on them over the last two decades.
I ask that you please support the retired public safety workers and vote in favor of House Bill 571 and those desperately needing COLA adjustments.
Thank you and I will answer any questions.
Thank you.
Are there any questions?
Seeing none, thank you very much.
Is there anyone else who wishes to testify on House Bill 571?
Mr.
Kavanaugh has an update.
Thank you.
I want to clarify a mistake I made.
There was a permanent cola in 2020 of 1.5%.
I have here and I can provide this for you.
This is a now you know publication that we put out on various topics available on our website.
On the reverse, has the history of the colas and go through that very briefly from 2003 to 2006 it was 1% a true cola 2007 it was two and a quarter percent 2008 in 2010 it was 1.5 percent in 2011 and 12 there was a temporary allowance not a true cola of 500 or a thousand dollars depending on your benefit.
From 2013 to 2017 there was no cola and no temporary allowance.
18 there was a temporary allowance.
19 there was none.
2020 there was the 1.5 percent.
2021 there was a temporary allowance.
19, there was none.
2020, there was the 1.5%.
2021, there was none.
And 2022 was a $500 temporary supplemental allowance, which is a one-time payment.
So I apologize for speaking incorrectly before.
Thank you.
We'd appreciate having that information.
Any other questions?
All right.
Oh, we'll get them.
Thank you.
All right.
Does anyone else wish to speak on House Bill 571?
all right.
Seeing none, I will close the hearing.
This bill is going to the Pension Subcommittee for analysis.
And we will resume at 1 p.m.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
Welcome back.
I'm opening the hearing on House Bill 436, and I call Representative Pratt.
He'll give us a pink card when he's done.
Oh, he has one?
I'll have somebody else up here.
Thank you.
I have a Thank you.
I have me speak today on House Bill 436.
This is a bill relative to the retirement system.
It's under the provisions of the retirement system.
You probably have the bill in front of you and there's a financial study at the end of it so as we study the retirement system i see a lot of new faces here people have been around for a while they understand what's going on with the retirement system i'll be really brief but um quite a few years ago the system was underfunded it went undefended for about 20 years.
And then about 10 years ago, the retirement system got revoked.
And at that time, basically the state stopped funding the state of New Hampshire retirement system.
It's being funded right now by the towns and by the individuals in Group 2.
So their shares went way up.
So I understand that the cost is an issue and that's why just a little history of that.
So as we try to work on the retirement system, in order to get numbers to be able to work, the only way to get numbers from the retirement system actuaries is to file a bill.
So we filed two bills here.
There's like 14 14 all together i think but we filed two of them one of them is 436 the other one you'll hear later on about two o'clock is number 525.
they're very close to the same kind of bill uh excuse me could you explain who we is we well it's Okay, fair enough.
No problem.
I just wasn't sure if you were the king or you had other people.
I'm the only one on this bill here, but on the second bill we filed, Representative Trotter and Bordes were signed on that bill.
They tried to get on this bill, but they didn't get on in time.
But those are the three people that signed on that bill.
There's a lot of people behind us that agree with the path were taken they may speak afterwards so bill 436 adjust the application of the minimum age minimum years of service annuity multiplications multipliers and and for group two service retirement.
In 2011, let's see, January 1st of 2014, if you look down through the bill, you'll see where the date has changed on our bill.
That's the first thing you notice when you look at the bill.
So by doing that, it's going to take care of two years of people that are getting close to retirement.
For the people that have been on this committee for a while, they understand that there's a problem in group two.
Guards at the jail, firemen and policemen aren't coming to the job like they used to.
The retirement system is one of the big reasons for that.
And then some people are leaving early, so the combination of nobody coming in and people leaving early is causing almost a crisis situation.
You'll hear from the guards at the jail, and they're working a lot of overtime.
And firemen are working a lot of overtime, policemen are working overtime to fill the gap of all these people that aren't here.
So we understand that from last year and the year before, as we talked about this.
So as we change the date to 2014 from 2012, that will take care of the next group of people that are retiring.
This bill will go into effect not immediately.
And by doing that, this bill and the next bill, we hope to encourage people to stay a few more years.
That'll help a lot in the situation as opposed to having people come out, leave and retire the system early.
So then you get down into the chart.
The chart is where the real changes are made.
On this bill, we changed the minimum years of service.
It used to be 20 years, and now it was changed to 21, 22, and 23 minimum years of service.
We're changing that by one year instead of going all the way back to 20 years.
It's a step scale, and it's only one year change.
And then the minimum age to retire at one point was 40.
And now it's 48, 47, and 46.
It's getting a little bit into the dangerous age here.
If you're inside of a house and you need somebody to rescue you, you don't want somebody too old coming to get you.
So 48 is right up there.
So we brought it down from 49, 48 to 47, 47 to 46.
That's just one year there.
And then on the annuity multiplier, the annuity multiplier used to be at 2.5.
So every year you worked, you got 2.5 in your retirement system out of your base pay.
That 2.5 was changed down to 2.4, down to 2.3, 2.2, and 2.1.
So we're coming up 0.1%.
Just 1%.
And that's quite a bit of money just to do that, but really badly needed in order to get this system back where it belongs.
I understand that there is a study committee, and the study committee will be working on all these bills together.
Does anybody have a question?
I don't see any.
That was easy.
Okay.
Yeah, it's a subcommittee, not a study committee.
So I'll be back at 2 to speak about the other bill.
Okay, thank you.
Yeah.
Yes.
Mr.
Kavanaugh.
Thank you, Madam Chair.
Again, for the record, I'm Mark Kavanaugh, Associate Counsel and Compliance Officer for the New Hampshire Retirement System.
I just wanted to start with a brief overview because this afternoon we are looking at four bills that all address the same issue.
You may have in front of you this chart that shows how benefits are currently provided for Group 2s.
As the prior speaker mentioned, in 2011, the benefit structure was changed.
Persons who were vested had 10 years of service as of January 1st, 2012, kept the old benefit.
Retire at age 45, 20 years of service, get 2.5% for each year.
Persons hired after 1-1-12, whole new setup.
You've got to be older.
You've got to be 52 and a half.
You've got to have 25 years of service.
In between, you have those who were already working but were not vested on January 1st.
That's who we're talking about here.
It's a cohort of about 1, about 1700 people um these are their rules were changed so that depending on how much service you had between zero and 9.9 years you would be on this tiered chart that specified uh the age starting at 46 up to, the years of service 21 up to 26.
What this particular bill does is take those who were between eight and nine years as of 1112, close to vestigium but not quite, who currently are required to have 21 years of service at age 46, is going to put that group, just that group, those who had 89 years of service, back into the old rules, age 45, 20 years, in a 2.5% multiplier.
The other effect it has is it also then makes the old definition of earnable compensation applicable to them.
And that means in particular, certain types of what we call compensation over base that are not counted when calculating your retirement are back in.
Those being primarily payouts of sick and vacation accruals.
That's the biggest element of those.
For these people currently, because they were not vested, those wouldn't account when calculating.
Now they're back in for those folks.
So by allowing these people to retire earlier, giving them an increased multiplier, as well as the old expanded definition, that's where we come up with the cost estimate for this bill, which is in fiscal year 2026 would be $2,820,000 for the state, $12,520,000 for the local political subdivisions.
That's an annual cost.
It is also estimated that this would add $133.6 million to the unfunded liability.
I finally would just like to speak to the comment that this would perhaps assist in recruiting and retention.
It's not going to assist in recruiting because it doesn't affect new hires.
And I'm not sure if it will help with retention because by its nature, the bill is designed to allow people to retire earlier, not later.
And so i'd open it up for questions thank you i take it that the hundred hundred thirty three point six million would be the cost to terminally fund it correct thank you are there questions represent o'brien thank you i am not sponsoring this one so thank you madam chair i checked for double checking Thank you.
I am not sponsoring this one, so thank you, Madam Chair.
I checked.
For double-checking.
Thank you.
Mr.
Kavanaugh, thank you for taking my question.
It may not be under your jurisdiction to worry about items such as spirit decor that exists within the departments, whether you're a policeman, fireman, or whatever.
But when you have multiple tiers like this, it could have an adverse effect.
Like you say, it may not affect the hiring and everything, but people who are currently under that employment can affect it the way that they feel, particularly when one person is getting a better benefit as compared to another one that's on the same shift, eating the same meal and fighting the same fire, per se.
I'll take your word for it.
Yeah, okay.
Well, follow up if I may.
Your question, Representative O'Brien.
Well, the thing is that have you heard from any of the chiefs or anything else like that that would support this because of the spare decor issues?
Representative O'Brien, we have a number of people who are testifying who will be more inclined to do this.
Thank you, Madam Chair.
And the answer is no.
People don't call me about that kind of thing.
Okay.
Thank you.
Yeah, really.
But I just would say also that we don't take a position on any of these bills.
I just want to make that clear.
These are policy decisions, 100%.
And secondly, 60% of our Group 2 members were hired after 1-1-12.
So that's a large percentage.
Really, that's more than I would have thought.
Thank you.
It surprised me when I saw the number two.
Okay.
Any other questions?
Representative Fitzpatrick.
Thank you, Madam Chair.
Just for clarification, what this would do was bring a person's benefits back to what they were told the benefits were when they were hired.
Is that correct?
In other words, they were hired when they were told.
But it would put them back to where the benefits were before the law changed at the time.
Right, but the way that it's written.
Yes.
Okay, thank you.
Other questions?
Representative True.
Thank you, Madam Chair, and thank you for taking my question.
You're welcome.
You had covered this, but you went by it so quickly I forgot.
I should have written it down.
Who does this apply to again and why?
This applies to Group 2 police and firefighters and corrections officers who were hired prior to January 1st of 2012, but were not, I'm sorry, July 1st of 2011, but were not vested by January 1st, 2012.
So people who were working when the law changed and had somewhere between 0.1 and 9.9 years of service, but they hadn't quite, some of them reached vesting.
And their benefits were changed such that they had to work longer, they had a lower multiplier, and they had to be a little bit older to retire.
This bill is intended to restore one portion of those people back to what the benefits were prior to the change in law.
Yes, Representative Troup.
Thank you, Madam Chair.
How many?
That was 1,700 people, maybe?
In the whole group of what we call non-vesteds.
I don't know the number of people who would be impacted specifically by this statute because it only applies to those who had between eight and 10 years of service as of 1-1-12.
It also affects people with less service, but not as dramatically.
Correct.
Thank you.
Okay.
Any other questions?
All right.
Thank you very much mr cavanaugh catherine heke or heck good afternoon chairman mcguire members of the committee for the record my name is Katherine heck I represent the New Hampshire Municipal Association and we are here today to oppose this bill I had sent in written testimony and it's not on the policy proposal or what it's looking to change it's solely on the cost that would be borne by the municipalities.
So our only comment is that our members take a position that they have adopted, that any changes to benefits resulting in increased costs, we are asked to oppose on their behalf.
And if the state chooses to terminally fund this program and having no impact on municipalities, we would have no position on the bill or any other bill with a cost associated with it so there's no policy opposition solely cost all right thank you for that are there any questions seeing none thank you for your testimony brian rill good afternoon madam chair members of the committee once again my name is brian rill i'm the president of professional firefighters in new hampshire um in the interest of of time and respecting committee's time, I'm going to provide my testimony, and I'd ask that you please apply equally to House Bill 436, House Bill 525, and House Bill 579, respectively, as I believe the intent of each of these bills is to accomplish a similar goal.
So I will not be testifying on the other two.
Madam Chair, I'm just going to speak broadly about the retirement system and where we're at.
The state of our fire service is deeply troubling at the moment.
Throughout the state, we're witnessing the lowest recruitment and retention numbers that we've seen in the last 10 years.
In the mid to late 2000s, the New Hampshire CPAT exam, the candidate physical agility test, saw well over 500 candidates annually, and today we barely see 200.
The recruitment and retention crisis is linked to the sweeping retirement changes that were made in 2011.
The trends show a consistent decline in applicants since January of 2012.
Simply put, firefighters, police officers, and correctional officers are wondering if the prolonged physical and emotional stress of a dedicated career in public service is truly worth the deteriorating retirement benefit.
it.
Now members who are becoming retirement eligible are realizing that they can't afford to retire at all and those that bear witness to their struggles are choosing to leave prematurely.
We heard a statistic that 60% if I heard correctly of our members in the group 2 system were hired after the changes were made and that may be so but I will tell you that we are just now seeing those that were impacted by those changes technically becoming eligible to retire they're realizing what their benefits actually going to be and those that have come after them are seeing that as well and they're not sticking around to wait and become retirement eligible.
They're leaving prematurely.
Lawmakers on both sides of the aisle and all chambers of the Statehouse have acknowledged that New Hampshire is suffering from this recruitment and retention epidemic, and it's like none we've ever seen.
A staggering amount of these lawmakers have agreed that passing positive, substantial retirement legislation is the long-term solution.
Madam Chair, that very opportunity is now before the members of this committee.
You all have the ability to begin to change the narrative of public safety in New Hampshire once and for all, and I implore you to take action.
There are a number of retirement bills before you, and I suspect a lot of collaboration to be done to find the right solution.
It's likely that some or all of the retirement bills heard today will be referred to the pension subcommittee, and I would like to express our support for that process.
However, when working through this process, I would kindly ask the committee to take an approach aimed to do the most good for the most people.
I heard that from the retirement system, there were approximately 1,700 firefighters, police officers, and correctional officers.
My numbers are slightly off, so your written testimony that you may have from me cites 1824.
That number did come from the retirement system, but it may not be the most up to date.
I would certainly take the gentleman's word from the system on the accuracy of the numbers.
But I will say even with that, that number in the sliding scale and a total of somewhere around 4,500 still in the system altogether in group two, the concept of providing a substantive change for a small subset of individuals is concerning to the firefighters.
For example, passing legislation that would only impact that group of members with eight to 10 years in the system at the time of the 2011 changes will leave approximately 80% of that sliding scale feeling as though they are once again being left behind.
And I believe this would perpetuate the problem.
I would ask that if referred to committee, along with the other retirement bills, we look to see how we can make positive, impactful changes to the most number of people.
It is no longer conjecture to say that we're hemorrhaging firefighters, police officers, and correctional officers in our great state, and we have reached the point public safety in new hampshire is a liability the time for action is now madam chair on behalf of the professional firefighters of new hampshire i would ask for this committee's unanimous support to move towards progressive and substantial improvements to group 2 retirement and i would like to offer my support or information that may be relevant to this committee or that of the subcommittee as we move forward to find solutions.
Thank you all for handling what is likely the most difficult task this session, and I appreciate all of your support for your firefighters.
I'd be happy to answer any questions.
Thank you for your testimony.
Questions?
Representative O'Brien.
Thank you, Madam Chair, and thank you, Brother Rill, for taking my question.
Prior to 2011, am I correct in understanding that the employee paid nine and three-quarter% towards the retirement, and then when they changed the law, it jumped up to 12.8%.
So the employees are paying for some of the changes that were affected by this.
So even though there was a cut to their benefits, they are paying more in their weekly contributions into the New Hampshire retirement system.
Am I correct in assuming that?
Yes, you're correct.
The employee contribution is 11.8%, but yes, we are paying more towards our own benefit, the benefit that was taken in 2011.
That's correct.
I'd like to say that that amount is paid by all firefighters, no matter what their pension calculation would be.
Isn't that true?
That's correct.
I'll stipulate.
Very good.
Other questions?
Representative Broda.
Thank you.
Mr.
Will, you mentioned that there was a decrease in the number of people who are applying for firefighter positions.
And do you have some numbers behind, I mean, is there information that you can give to us that would help us?
You don't have to do it right now.
You can send it to us by email.
The number of applicants that you've received that have applied to this position from 2012, the last 10 years.
Sure.
Yeah, we can get that information for you.
The New Hampshire Fire Standards and Training keeps track of that.
and it has been published actually in the recent recruitment and retention report the state had put together a recruitment and retention committee that looked at some of these numbers and they identified a steady decline since 2011 which we can show you the numbers for but they.
And in addition to that, one of the changes that they cited in that report was restoring benefits back to pre-2011 changes was in order to help recruitment and retention.
Thank you, Madam Chair.
And have the tests, especially like the physical tests, have they remained the same so that it's not more challenging to be?
I'm just checking.
To my knowledge, the physical agility test has not changed in a significant number of years.
Okay, thank you so much.
Representative Gerhardt.
Thank you, Madam Chair.
Forgive me if I i missed it are you a firefighter yourself yes sir i'm a captain in portsmouth the boards with fire department okay thank you other uh questions all right seeing none thank you for your testimony and we will expect your participation in the subcommittee claudia prescott hello madam chair thank you looks like our ranks are increasing i just wanted to speak because he had some good questions.
So my name is Officer Claudia Prescott.
I've been employed for 17 years at the New Hampshire Department of Corrections are almost 17 years now.
So yeah, I just want to address some of the issues that have come up thus far.
Yes, this bill only this particular bill only speaks to a couple of years it does address some of us that are further down so it would help someone like myself who had less than six years so it would it would address me a little bit but I'm not in that group that would get everything back that I was promised when I was hired or that if you go to website, it still says to this day that you get your best five years.
That's never been accurate.
I don't know why it's still on there.
So it's been very misleading.
So when I was hired, I was told I would get my best three years and a number of other benefits that were changed in 2011.
But it was never changed to our best five years, despite what their PowerPoints, their YouTube channel, and everything all over their website led us to believe for the next over decade into this day.
It still says that.
So that sucks.
But anyway, that's not going to happen.
What this would do, it would restore some of the parity anyway for people that were hired, that did go through the academy and have served for all these years right alongside other officers, firefighters, and policemen.
Literally, they were hired together.
They went through the academy together, and they've served their entire careers.
Only the people that they went through the academy with are under the old deal and they actually get their best three and they get everything that both officers were promised and these other people because they were hired maybe a couple of days or a month or so later get the entire new deal so um yeah that's a huge morale issue and so it does really help those officers it me a little bit, but I think it's a really huge deal for those people that literally missed it by, you know, a tiny little bit.
So it is a huge deal for them.
And it is a huge morale issue.
because yeah, I've served alongside those people that paid less into it because the contribution rates have changed significantly over the years.
I think you all know that certainly the cost is a factor.
The people that got the old deal, they got their best three, their bank out, and all the things that I was promised when I was hired and for the first nearly six years of my career, they paid in less.
They got everything.
I pay in more.
I've paid in more my entire career, and I got less, and my taxes were raised.
The state now contributes less, so when our contribution went up, the state contributed less.
So the municipalities, well, they got a tax holiday because the market was doing fantastic.
Now they have to contribute a little, and they did that by raising our taxes.
And I, like most people, I'm a taxpayer in the state of New Hampshire, as of our both my children.
The market was doing fantastic.
Now they have to contribute a little.
And they did that by raising our taxes.
And I, like most people, I'm a taxpayer in the state of New Hampshire, as of our both my children.
So, you know, we got it on all ends.
So we contribute more, we get less.
And then we got nailed with our taxes as well.
So we pay a lot more and we got a lot less out of it.
So, yeah, it's a morale issue.
It's definitely a money issue.
I totally understand that.
I don't know what else came up.
The standards have been lowered for us at the Department of Corrections.
In 2010, the legislature, we have a budget office, did a legislative budget audit.
It's really interesting.
Great read.
I encourage you guys to read it.
they did an audit and they said at the men's prison at the time we had 241 officers and they were concerned about our staffing ratios at the time we now have around 130 left so our recruitment and retention to say has been lagging that doesn't even begin to encompass it we areERS, COTs, BALLERINAS, ANYTHING TRYING TO COVER THOSE SHIFTS.
WE CAN'T DO IT.
WE'RE RUNNING BELOW MINIMUM ALL THE TIME.
IT'S INCREDIBLY UNSAFE.
SO YEAH, WE'RE WORKING INCREDIBLE HOURS.
THAT'S UNSAFE.
WE'RE RUNNING BELOW MINIMUM.
I MEAN, I THINK PART OF IT, A HUGE PART OF IT, ISN'T JUST it, isn't just the fact that the changes were made.
It's the fact that the state lost credibility.
How can you enter into a contract and renege on a contract?
I mean, I told my daughters who are both nurses, don't go work for the state because you can't believe what you have in writing.
I mean, that's what happened to me.
I had almost six years in.
I believed what I was told when I was hired.
I believed, that's what happened to me.
I had almost six years in.
I believed what I was told when I was hired.
I believe that was a contract.
Wouldn't you?
Wouldn't anybody?
I mean, if you have a deal with a roofer, would they put half your roof on and then change?
So yeah, I told both my nurses, don't go work for the state because you can't believe anything they say.
And I think is a problem I think that's a problem we have is that you can't trust the state and I think that the best way to rectify that in my opinion and that's my opinion we all have those is to honor the commitment that the state made to us when they hired us is to do the honorable thing we We were told one thing when we were hired and it was retroactively changed for 10 years.
And then for the next 11 years, we were told something else and that was also changed.
We literally hire people to this day telling them it's gonna be their best five years and that's just not true and if you can't go to the new hampshire retirement web website to get good information where can you go any questions okay thank you very much for your testimony are there any questions thank you very much jennifer fleming uh michael giha thank you madam chair my name is michael giha i'm a detective with the salem Police Department and I'm currently serving as the president of the New Hampshire Police Association.
Today this committee is hearing several bills relating to Group 2 retirement.
The brief comments I want to share with you all are somewhat general in nature.
So I will say them now instead of testifying on every bill.
There are some bills we believe make sense, but some were published without the fiscal notes being available.
So it is difficult to determine which ones we support more strongly.
That will become clearer as you get this information.
Having said that, I want to convey the importance of making some changes to the Group 2 system to help states, cities, towns recruit and retain police officers.
I'm sure you all have heard the challenges law enforcement is facing today.
The availability of new hire police officers is at a record low, making for an extremely challenging employment pipeline.
Existing police officers are departing earlier than we ever seen before, putting extreme pressure on police departments across the state.
The one area that we believe can have a positive impact on recruitment, and especially retention, is changes within our retirement system.
Nearly 12 years ago, the state took steps to deal with retirement funding issues at that time no one could have contemplated the workforce situation we face today but some of those changes are exact exasperating today's problem the most specific issue is the creation of the middle tier that you have previously heard about I know that group two stakeholder groups which include the New Hampshire Police Association, the New Hampshire Troopers Association, and the Professional Firefighters of New Hampshire among others are committed to working with you in a unified approach to see if something can be done that will help with the serious problem.
So today we ask that you assess these bills from the perspective of which ones might help with the recruitment and retention challenges that the state and local governments are facing.
As these bills go to the subcommittee for further review, we will be there to assist in any way we can.
Thank you.
Are there any questions?
Very good.
That's the last part I have for this bill.
Ms.
Fleming was for a different bill.
Is there anyone else who wishes to testify?
We've got time on this one, so you might as well do this one.
Representative Pearson.
I was expecting longer testimony.
I was expecting a little longer testimony.
Thank you, Madam Chair, for the record.
Representative Steve Pearson, Rockingham District 13 now, Derry.
I've served two terms on eDNA.
I'm in my third term in the House.
And I thank you all for listening.
One of the, excuse me one second.
One of the, one of the things I want to touch on here, and I have to, I have to read it is there's a, there's a piece in the New Hampshire state constitution that I think is very valuable here.
And that's Article 23.
Article 23 of the New Hampshire State Constitution basically says you can't make retroactive law.
And there's a reason for that.
Retroactive law, and I'll read directly from it, retrospective laws are highly injurious, oppressive, and unjust.
No such laws, therefore, should be made.
That was done in 1784.
So please understand that the circumstances that we're in right now here involve something that was done retrospectively.
And the founders of the state of New Hampshire in this great document recognized back then that doing things retrospectively would cause problems.
And that's why we're here today.
Listening to the great testimony that I heard from various folks, I want to bring up a couple of other quick points here.
When the employee rates were changed in 2011 as part of this restructuring, the rates that Group 2 employees in New Hampshire pay is the highest in New England.
And in one particular case, it's double.
Now we talk about the bleed that's going on here with folks.
The city of Manchester, as an example,'s police department has lost 47 officers in the last 18 months.
That's 25% of their police department has gone in 18 months.
That is beyond crisis level.
As a matter of fact, the union leader did a good article on it a little while ago.
The state prison system has hundreds of vacancies, and they have come up with creative and frankly dangerous ways to try to deal with that.
And the other circumstance that we're now seeing that we never really saw before is that we have communities that are stealing employees from each other.
Now, generally speaking, the larger communities will benefit from that, including mine.
Derry has a little bit bigger of a budget to absorb having to train new people.
But if you're from a small town and you've got five police officers, you can't afford to have one leave every year because frankly, you don't have the budget to train someone to small town and you've got five police officers, you can't afford to have one leave every year because frankly, you don't have the budget to train someone to replace them.
So a serious deep dive needs to occur here.
This is a problem that was forecasted 10 years ago and the warning signs, what those warning signs were done with is up for debate.
Most of them were frankly ignored.
But the actual crisis that's before us now is far worse than was even predicted in 2011.
So I just ask that this subcommittee especially really take a deep look at this.
Look at what the other states have done and what they haven't done.
None of them, by the way, not a single other New England state went retroactive.
Other New England states made changes, but they were all for new hires.
Only New Hampshire went backwards.
And I think that should tell you quite a bit right then and there.
So I appreciate this committee's time.
I know it's complicated when you have several bills that seem to be going in the same direction, but please understand the concept is generally the same here as to what the problem is, because the problem is the same regardless of the bill number.
So I would certainly entertain any questions you have.
Thank you, Representative Pearson.
Are there any questions?
Representative Shewitt.
Thank you, Madam Chair.
Thank you, Representative Pearson.
thank you representative pearson are there any questions representative shuett thank you madam chair thank you representative pearson um the constitution section that you cited uh was that law that was passed in 2011 challenged in court on that basis not on that basis the law the challenge that was done in court in 2011 was based on a contract clause, which the courts determined that there is no contract.
The word contract actually doesn't exist in the language of group two that I can find, or the pension system period.
But it was not challenged under Article Article 23.
It should have been, but was not.
Other questions?
All right.
Seeing none, thank you for your time.
Thank you, Madam Chair.
And I'm not sure when the subcommittee will meet, but I'm sure you will get involved.
Is there anyone else who wishes to testify on house bill 436 mr rill you have thank you madam chair i just wanted to let the committee know uh we just emailed a copy of that recruitment and retention report so you should thank you very much that will be helpful anyone else okay then i'll close the hearing on house bill 436 and it will be going to the pension subcommittee we have a few minutes before the next hearing Thank you.
Thank you.
Okay.
I'd like to mention that we do have fiscal notes for all these bills.
There's copies over on that table and we we have received the recruitment and retention report and also a comment from the retirement system explaining their uh average their final average final calculation data so and yes i'm opening the ON HOUSE BILL 449 AND I CALL REPRESENTATIVE GOLEY.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
FOR THE RECORD, REPRESENTATIVE JEFF GOLEY REPRESENTAT Representative Jeff Goley representing Hillsborough 21, which is Manchester Ward 1.
Here today to introduce House Bill 449.
and like the previous bill this is another attempt to rework the tiers that we have currently in group two and bringing more members who had their multipliers reduced and their ages increased more towards the system that they were hired under.
And I will go directly to page one of the bill.
And if you go down to line 12 where those changes start and actually to line 20 and what it does is it puts the for those will be commence service on or after July 1st 2011 it puts the two and a half multiplier back in for the first 20 years and then it puts them back to the 2% multiplier for anything after that subsequent years and it goes if you follow down through it's less than four years it does the two and a half multiplier for anything after that subsequent years.
And it goes, if you follow down through, it's less than four years.
It does the two and a half multiplier for the first 20 years, and then 2.1% for subsequent years and further on down that chart.
So it's another attempt, like the previous bill and the other bills coming forward, to put those folks who were promised a benefit and what they were hired under, getting them closer to what they had been hired under and thought they had prior to being vested.
I think the important thing with this bill is it doesn't just address a couple of years of folks, that it addresses a bigger group.
And I think policy-wise, if we're going to address the issue, that they all ought to be included in a solution that we aim to or strive to put forward.
So that's why this bill was filed.
There are other folks behind me that can answer questions.
But I think in the previous bill, you understand where we're going with these number of bills.
And there's just different ways and different solutions to trying to solve a problem.
Thank you, Representative Goley.
Does this bill address everyone in the transition group one way or another?
Yes, it will.
Thank you.
That's what I wanted to know.
Any other questions that you think Representative Goley might want to answer?
Representative Broda.
Thank you.
So Representative Goley, this essentially will eliminate that tier system that was created, or will it leave, or it will reduce that tier?
Correct.
Okay.
Thank you.
All right, thank you very much for your testimony.
Mr.
Kavanaugh.
Thank you again for the record, Mark Kavanaugh, Associate Counsel and Compliance Officer for the New Hampshire Retirement System.
This bill takes a different approach by restoring the 2.5 multiplier for the first 20 years of service, and then depending on where the transitional folks were on the old tier, they'll have variable multipliers from 2.1 to 2.4 for any years over 20.
This also applies not just to the transition this would apply to anyone hired after one one.
I mean 7 1 2011 who currently have a 2.0 multiplier for all years.
So there's a substantial amount of the cost that for 60% of our group twos were hired after that date who will have an increase in the multiplier as well and that's why we come up with the costs of in the fiscal notes but 3.5 million for the state in 13.3 million for the political subdivisions in 2026 for contributions.
And a $82.2 million increase in the accrued liability.
Once this has been amortized out, there will be a permanent effect on the rates of $1.9 for police and AND 1.99 FOR FIRE IN PERPETUITY.
THAT'S 1.99 PERCENT PERCENTAGE POINTS MORE THAN WHAT THE CURRENT RATES ARE.
SO I WOULD OPEN TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS.
OKAY.
THANK YOU.
questions?
Representative Dolan.
I would note also that there are some states who have similar arrangements, but they do it the other way around.
They have a higher multiplier after 20 years to encourage people to stick around.
Thank you, Madam Chair.
The, I have a question kind of out of left field, but we heard some stories earlier today about some of the extraordinary things that agencies are doing to hire or try to fill these open positions that they have.
Should we put any ominous restrictions in place through either legislative action or administration?
they have have we put any ominous restrictions in place through either legislative action or administrative action that limits retirees from being hired back it says that yeah you're retired but if you want to come back and work as a retired firefighter or as a retired prison guard or whatever, we'll welcome you to do that without giving severe penalties to the...
There are annual limitations on work hours.
So if you were to retire now, you can come back to work up to 1,352 hours per calendar year.
That equates to about 26 hours a week.
if you had retired prior to 2019 you can work up to 1664 which equates to 32 hours a week those rehirees aren't penalized with everything not as long as they stay they can collect their pension work part-time as long as they stay below those hourly limits if they go over then they will be their pension will be docked for 12 months in the next year uh by approximately 50 does that need to be reviewed it was we took there yes we talked about it there is no restriction on a retiree choosing to come back to work full time it's only if they want to collect their pension and work part-time that there are limitations.
Okay, thank you.
And they're free to work in the private sector as much as they want.
Yes, or go across one of the borders and work for a government in Massachusetts or Maine or wherever.
Okay.
Other questions?
All right.
Thank you very much.
You're welcome.
Brian Rill.
Thank you, Madam Chair, members of the committee.
I promise this is the last time you'll see me today.
My name is Brian Rowe, and once again, I serve as the president of Professional Firefighters in New Hampshire, and I'm a captain for the city of Portsmouth Fire Department.
You know, it's been mentioned a couple times before, but our job here with the professional firefighters is to advocate for the men and women that serve the citizens of this state every single day, without question, without fail.
And the least we can do is take a look at some of these retirement changes in 2011 and try to make it right.
I sit before you today in full support of hospital 449 relative to the couch.
changes in 2011 and try to make it right.
I sit before you today in full support of House Bill 449 relative to the calculation of Group 2 retirement benefits in our system.
Today I speak to you not only as a proud leader of some of the bravest men and women in our state, but also someone who is a profound concern for the future of public safety in New Hampshire.
A noble calling that was once highly desirable continues to suffer in the face of a recruitment and retention epidemic like none we've ever seen.
In the mid to late 2000s as I mentioned earlier New Hampshire's fire state entrance exam saw well over 4500 candidates.
Many of those candidates came in with brand new fire science degree, associate's degree from the Tech College here in New Hampshire.
Some had a paramedic certificate.
In either case, they were highly desirable and highly marketable to the average fire department.
And despite this, most often struggled to find a job in what was once a highly competitive market.
Now that very same test that's yielding approximately 60% fewer candidates, many fire departments are left unable to hire enough qualified applicants to fill their open positions.
And these lack of new recruits joining the ranks, those that are in the fire service are being asked in many cases told to have to work more, to do more.
And this has created a volatile situation, which has resulted in the loss of highly qualified and experienced personnel, with an underwhelming number of candidates ready to fill these positions.
When dedicating oneself to a career in public service, most recognize that they do so for a modest wage, fair benefits, and a dignified retirement.
Unfortunately, I'm here to tell you today that the latter no longer exists.
In fact, over the years, the expectations of this job have become much higher than ever before, the risks far greater, and the retirement less enticing.
Madam Chair, members of the committee, I can say with incredible certainty that this is the reason for our recruitment and retention crisis.
In 2022, the Department of Safety established a Recruitment and Retention Ad Hoc Committee.
That report is now in your inbox.
That committee recommended supporting initiatives and legislations that ensured retirement security for members of the New Hampshire retirement system, such as, but not limited to, returning the New Hampshire retirement system benefit structure to the pre-2011 levels.
House Bill 449 not only represents a partial restoration of a benefit that was once removed from members in 2011, but it is the one singular retirement bill being heard by this committee that positively impacts all firefighters, police officers, and corrections personnel, not just those in that sliding scale.
Passing this legislation shows that the committee recognizes New Hampshire's recruitment and retention crisis and is willing to make meaningful, impactful changes to stop the bleeding.
I would urge this committee's full support to send House Bill 449 to the subcommittee so that this can be further reviewed.
And I would take any questions.
Thank you.
Thank you for your testimony.
Are there any questions?
Professor Angerhard, do you have a quick help?
Okay.
In that case, thank you very much.
Thank you.
Frank Campo?
There we go.
Good afternoon, Madam Chair and committee members.
My name is Frank Campo.
I'm a sergeant with the state police and i serve as the president of the new hampshire troopers association you've heard a great deal today about the serious recruitment and retention problems law enforcement's having and i'd like to put this into perspective for you all a little bit currently the state police has about 70 vacancies which puts us at nearly a 20 vacancy rate this is as serious a problem as I've ever seen in my 20 years in law enforcement.
Recruitment is extremely difficult and troopers are leaving and retiring and creating a serious retention problem that we're having.
We strongly believe that making changes to the retirement system can help address this problem.
The bill before you, House Bill 449, is one approach that will help.
Increasing the service retirement and disability retirement annuity multiplier for the first 20 years of service for Group 2 system members under the transitions adopted in 2011 will serve as a strong incentive to stay longer.
And this is a goal that we should all be working for.
And I realize that you have a lot of bills and ideas before you that would make changes to the retirement to help deal with the recruitment and retention problem.
The men and the women who make up the state police would appreciate it if you would weigh each of these bills with that goal in mind.
If not this bill, there are other approaches in front of you.
And I would just like to address one issue that Mr.
Kavanaugh spoke of earlier, that these bills will not do much for retention.
I would wholeheartedly disagree with that.
I can think off the top of my head right now, five or six of my friends, other troopers that had 10 plus years on with the division have left because of the changes to the retirement system that took place.
It simply wasn't worth it for them to stay.
So they simply left.
And if there's anything that you can remember from my testimony today, I hope it is that we have a serious problem and it's getting worse and adjusting retirement benefits can have a positive impact towards this.
Thank you.
And I can take any questions if there are any.
Representative Brody.
Thank you.
I'm sympathetic to the situation and I agree that something has to be done.
My concern is that we have a 20 percent vacancy rate over the state agencies.
So how sure are you that returning the or passing this legislation will indeed allow you to hire individuals how is that pool going to get bigger sure well i think um what you what you get is you know we always remember or we always know kind of growing up as kids that um the um the um retirement for police officers is excellent and this has been watered down for the past 10 years or so.
And what has happened is you're starting to see that it's now starting to catch up.
These people are understanding that, okay, I guess the retirement in New Hampshire isn't that good.
We're not going to go into law enforcement service in New Hampshire.
Maybe if we want to, we'll go elsewhere to another adjoining state or maybe to the federal level or maybe not get into law enforcement whatsoever.
It will take some time, I think, to turn this around.
But if some of these benefits begin to get restored and people start to understand that the retirement is worth it up here in New Hampshire, they're going to come back.
Yes.
And you think that this type of legislation or this kind of benefit increase or return back to normal is going to be enough to do that?
I do.
I think it would be.
And I certainly I know it would be enough to retain the employees that we had these, you know, the handful that I spoke of earlier.
earlier these are gentlemen with 10 plus years on the job they left here with um you know a lot of experience a lot of training, and you can't put a number on, you know, making that back up.
I agree.
Thank you so much.
Representative Dolan.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
From a state police viewpoint, my question is going to be, I know we have a similar problem in Rockingham County with the nursing home.
Our nursing home is hiring nurses and maintaining a full staff there.
So they've done some extraordinary things with tuition reimbursement, bonuses, and so forth to aid in the recruitment.
My question to you is, again, as a state trooper, do you think those types of efforts would be effective?
It seems like right now we're hoping people are our we're hoping people are higher on and we got our fingers crossed what about extraordinary personnel actions to that maybe we could give to the subcommittee to look at like you can be as creative as you want bonuses tuition certain things to attract a larger pool that may be going off to maine or going off to massachusetts or whatever to for their jobs sure i'm not sure um i don't have a good answer on that i can say that um we currently the state police has a ten thousand dollar recruitment bonus and um it seems as if recruitment has picked up a little bit i don't have any numbers on this but i will also say that i know in this last class of recruits that we hired half of them didn't even know we that we had that recruitment bonus so i don't know how effective something like that um would be thank you thank Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
Representative Hebert.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
One of the first tasks that I had was a meeting with our local fire chief and our local police chief in Pelham.
And we're on a border town where we're losing quite a few officers and firefighters to Massachusetts.
Do you know if we put this in place, how it compares to Massachusetts?
And would this be the fix or would this be, would this continue to be a problem next year?
We're going to see this again next year.
Thank you.
I don't know.
I can't say that it would be a fix.
I could certainly say it would be helpful.
I honestly don't know what the retirement system down in Massachusetts looks like, so I wouldn't really be able to speak to that.
But I do know we've had several troopers leave to go specifically down to Massachusetts.
And the retirement portion of it really never enters the conversation.
Mr.
Chair, follow-up?
Yes.
Thank you.
So can you or someone in this room get that information to us?
I can, yes.
Thank you.
can you or someone in this room get that information to us?
I can, yes.
Other questions?
Thank you very much for your testimony, and I apologize for having been called out.
Art Beaudry.
Madam Chairman, members of the committee for the record, my name is Arthur Beaudry.
I represent the New Hampshire State Permanent Firefighters Retirement Association.
And I am a retired captain from the Manchester Fire Department, and I was a board member of the New Hampshire Retirement System Board of Trustees.
And I am here in favor of House Bill 449.
I'm not going to say a lot because I think a lot has already been said.
I would be willing to work with the subcommittee on all this legislation to try to get back the benefits that were lost to the members prior to 2011.
This transitional period, it was unprecedented at the time for benefits to be retroactive.
If you look at what they did for Group 1 in the same year, and I'm reading right out of the statute that for Group 1, provided, however, Group 1 members who commence service on or after July 1, 2011, shall not reserve service retirement until they reach age 65.
They didn't touch their multiplier.
So on Group 2, they eliminated the multiple, not eliminated, but they lowered the multiplier, plus they raised the age and years of service.
So you're working longer for less money.
They didn't do that with group one.
And with group one, it was anybody after July 1 of 11 was affected.
If you were before that, they didn't say if you weren't vested like it is in Group 2.
So I don't know why they did what they did to Group 2.
But we would like to see those benefits retained and reimbursed to our members.
And again, we would be willing to work with the committee and all this legislation to try to get what is fair and equitable to our members.
And like I said, it's been unprecedented to have something retroactive taken away.
And I'll answer any questions.
Thank you for your testimony.
Are there any questions?
Representative Garhart.
Thank you, Madam Chair.
It seems like, from what I've heard so far, I'm new to this, obviously, the retirement system is in a complete mess.
So would you be, are you supportive of having the individual members deal with their own retirement instead of giving it up to the state and having them deal with it?
Are you suggesting going to a defined contribution plan?
I'm just saying giving individual members the ability to decide what to do with their retirement.
I would oppose going to any other benefit other than the defined benefit plan.
Not to say that our members are not smart enough to take care of their own finances, but I can tell you there are a lot of people that will look at that part of money and they'll go out and buy an RV or buy a new car and then when it comes to retirement, they don't have any money.
So we're supportive of the defined benefit plan, and I would not support any other type of benefit.
Thank you.
Other questions?
Seeing none, thank you for your testimony.
Is there anyone else who wishes to testify on House Bill 449?
Okay.
Seeing none, I will close the public hearing hearing this bill is going to subcommittee and i was called out for an emergency scheduling meeting and the that subcommittee will be meeting next thursday afternoon if not sooner the speaker anticipates a short session.
So after the session, the subcommittee will be meeting on these bills.
All right.
I'm opening the hearing on House Bill 525.
Representative Pratt.
Looks like I cleared the room.
Thank you, Madam.
How effective of you.
Thank you for having let me speak.
This is going to be on Bill 525.
And listening to the previous speakers, I was negligent in not mentioning my past career.
I was a fire chief for 29 years and a fireman for 42.
And I was a commercial fireman for Seabrook Nuclear Power Plant as senior fire brigade leader for five five years.
And 18 years I was a fire standards and training commissioner at fire standards and training.
I did see the years where we had so many people, we had to hire extra trucks and extra people to put classes on, or the tests on, to hire people to put on the list.
And then I was there when they, 2011, when they changed everything, and the numbers went down and down on the people put in for the job so that made the list smaller and smaller and it did force the cities to go looking elsewhere for their people and a lot of them took them from smaller towns which is a natural order of things but it increased after 2011.
also i heard earlier a statement this bill is very close to the bill I already mentioned earlier today.
So I heard earlier that there was an increase in hiring of 60% in the system.
That was probably true because it was a mass exodus in 2011, 2012, right after the bill got changed, the retirement system got bad, so bad that a lot of people left.
They were concerned that they couldn't trust the system that it would change again and they wanted to get out so we lost a lot of people that were trained right after that happened so there probably was an increase of 60% but that was probably after we had 60% light leave so that's just need to put that in perspective so So this bill, 525, adjusts the application of the minimum age, the minimum years of service, and the annuity multipliers to the transition provisions of group two service retirement adopted in 2011.
So if you look at the financial claim here.
So as we did before, we changed the date from 2012 to 2014 in a couple places.
But the real story is down in the chart, and that's lines 14 through 23 on the bill.
The ages on this bill stays the same, and the years of service stays the same, but the multiplier was the only thing that changed in this bill.
So it's very close to the other bill except for those changes.
And as before I mentioned, the only way you can get numbers from the actuary is to file a bill.
so this gives us a little bit different numbers on the bills and the financial statements in the first one uh let's see if there's any other points i wanted to make and it's been brought up already that um after 2011 towns and firefighters were paying more into the retirement system.
The state was paying zero after that.
And we were paying more in, both the towns and the individuals.
And we were working longer, years, and ended up getting less out of the retirement system, less compensation.
So pay more and get less was what happened after 2011.
So that statement I'll verify also.
And any questions?
I don't see any.
Thank you for your testimony.
Mr.
Cavanaugh, do you have anything to add?
We see.
um mr kavanaugh do you have anything to add this is the same as the bill we first entertained after lunch with the exception that the age and years of service don't change uh the difference in cost is between that bill and this bill is very, very slight.
You can compare the fiscal notes, but very little difference, that adjustment, one or 2% difference.
The change in the multiplier is more significant.
Is that correct?
Correct.
Versus allowing someone to retire one year earlier by changing the age and service.
That's all I had.
I'm open to any questions.
I'll keep this moving.
Okay.
Not seeing old representative True.
Thank you, Madam Chair, and thank you for taking my question.
So on this bill, 449, this basically applies to current employees?
Yes.
It applies to employees who were active on 7-1-11 but not vested by 1-1-12.
So people who had between 0 and 9.9 years of service when the law changed in 2012.
Yes.
No retired member is affected by any of these bills because once you decide to retire, your pension is set.
Correct.
Okay.
Any other questions?
All right.
525.
Mr.
Regasa?
Yes.
Ah, good.
I pronounced it close enough that you could recognize it.
Good afternoon, everyone.
So, instead of speaking for all these four great bills that are before us, what I will do is I'll save you all the time, and then I'll save myself a time as I have to work second shift, and I'll testify and I'll run out.
My name is Seyfiel Ragasa.
I am the president of the New Hampshire Probation Pro Officers Command Staff Union.
And I am one of the affected people by the previous bill back in 2011.
So why these bills?
Why are we supporting these bills?
first and foremost, as you all know, we have been affected greatly and we are dealing with recruitment issues.
Currently, our agency, the Department of Correction, is offering $10,000 bonus just to bring people through the door.
And unfortunately, it isn't the $10,000 people want, it is more of that stability what other states that are offering next door.
And the challenge we are having is that our competitors next door are treating our state as a recruitment depot.
What we do is we hire employee, whether it is a police officer, a correctional officer.
We hire them.
We train them.
The state spends up to $100,000 plus a year.
And then as soon as they got that certificate, they moved it to the next state, right next door in Massachusetts.
They are hiring them for 20 years service and exchange.
What that does is we are losing now these trained personnel that were supposed to stay here, help here, contribute here.
Now we're losing them to the state next door.
I have currently about six or seven individuals on the waiting list on Massachusetts Department of Correction and we're gonna lose from the Department of Correction that we have personnel that we cannot afford to lose.
I, as a parole officer, right after this testimony, I'm going to stand a post and cover a post at the prison because they are understaffed regularly.
So these $10,000 incentives are not helping us.
The other troubling factor is that aside from my full-time job, I'm an urgent professor with Southern New Hampshire University and like every term I ask students, what do you want to do?
What's your goal when you graduate?
I get 15 out of 21 students telling me that as soon as they graduate, they go to the next state or to the federal government system.
Mainly it is because the retirement is no longer glamorous.
It's no longer a career, it's rather a job.
Years ago it was a career, 20-year career, so you came in, professional environment.
And one of the students have told me what his father had told him, that in 2012 his father was actually one of the affected person the rug was taken underneath from his feet and Who will basically fall was the same group?
So We are really this is this are the multiple layer of effect the recruitment being one of them losing an educated group of people and More importantly we're losing this youngster who are the contributing factors of this society so uh the bill was intended to help state save money i don't know how much was but i'm sure we have accomplished whatever we needed to accomplish back i don't think there was any lawmaker who was intent to create this shortage of staff in in a police and a correctional facility, state police.
That wasn't the intended goal, but we now realize that intended goal, we did not accomplish what we wanted to accomplish while we continue to lose our training personnel and we're being treated as a recruitment institution by other states, right within the New England area.
So I urge you all to consider what happened, not only to fix it, but also to reinsure.
The decision made that in 2012, it was a decision to stabilize the state retirement system.
But then we still have people with a bad taste in their mouths that they were hired under 20 years contract.
And then nine years after they work, just because they didn't have that two months to be vested, they were told, oh, sorry, the promise we made you many years ago is no longer valid.
Once the good governor Sununu had told me that promise made so our promise kept.
I think it is time for the men and women that are serving this state, it is time for us to show them that what we promised you when you were hired is what you will get.
And those who come in understanding what their hiring condition is even will be treated better, mainly because we want them to stay here.
I compare numbers of incidents.
I am an instructor in many disciplines, especially use of force.
I compare our officers' incidents, our streets.
We are almost second to none.
We have the best officers that we cannot afford to lose.
But we're losing our officers because of the retirement system, which isn't working and which is no longer appealing so uh i strongly support any any bill that you guys bring to correct that damage it is a damage uh i am a forgiving person and i will say that it was intended to work well but it didn't it is time to change it and i will take any question any of you might have for me.
Thank you for your testimony.
Are there questions?
Senator Dolan?
Thank you, Madam Chair, and thank you for taking questions.
My question is, as we look at probably the worst inflation that the country has seen in over 40 years.
Are we doing enough?
The Fed's response for Social Security recipients is to increase their Social Security by in excess of 8% this year.
Are we doing enough in the state to help our police officers and similar professions deal with this scourge of inflation that they're dealing with in their home economy?
So if we are comparing apple to apple with neighboring states, no, we're not doing enough.
We also, in 2011, when we changed that bill didn't just change it also changed the contribution of firemen and law enforcement officers to the state retirement system.
So my answer will be no we're not really doing enough for our first responders.
Thank you.
I'm not sure that relates to this bill but go on.
I wonder if you might be prepared during the subcommittee portion of this to bring forth whatever recommendations you might have for the state.
Absolutely.
With regard to that.
Thank you.
Other questions?
All right.
Seeing none, thank you very much for your testimony.
Thank very much madam all right does anyone else wish to testify on house bill 525 all right seeing none i will close the public hearing and without objection we'll go into executive session representative Representative Grotter, you have a motion?
I do.
I have a motion of ITL on House Bill 525.
And I'll second that.
I hope that the committee will support the motion because I find 525 and the House Bill 436, as the sponsor said, remarkably similar.
And I think we can work with one of these bills, and that's why.
I just don't think we need both.
And I'd like to say that because they address the same sections of law in very much the same way, we can't pass both of them.
They conflict with each other.
So we're holding, we will be working on 536 and keep the concepts of 525 in mind while we do so.
Does anyone else have a comment?
Okay.
In that case, the motion is inexpedient to legislate and the clerk can call the roll.
Representative Bailey.
Yes.
Representative True.
Representative Dolan.
Yes.
Representative LeBear.
Representative Gerhardt.
Yes.
The clerk votes yes.
Representative Grota.
Yes.
Representative Schuett.
He was here when the question was called, yes.
He was.
Representative Coley.
Yes.
Representative Schuett.
Representative Wilhelm.
Yes.
Representative Davis.
Representative Fitzpatrick.
Yes.
And the chair.
And we have a vote of 13 yay, zero nay.
Okay.
Is there any objection to consent?
I don't think that there can be because it's a fiscal note.
If the motion is ITL, you can put a bill on consent.
Okay.
You just can bill on consent.
You just can't pass it.
Okay.
And at your earliest convenience, Representative Grotta.
All right.
Leaving the executive session, I'll open the hearing on House Bill 579.
And Representative Trotier.
Good afternoon, Madam Chair and members of the ED&A Committee.
I am Representative Douglas Trotier, Belknap County District 8, which represents the towns of belmont tilton and sambiton today i come before you with house bill 579 i understand that this committee has heard several bills today on the retirement system so i'm going to make this very brief you've heard testimonies about the um changes back in 2011 that took effect in 2012 so this bill would eliminate the 2011 transition provision from the group to retirement returning it back to what it was prior to those changes for members that were hired before july 1 of 2011.
this bill would anybody hired after that it would remain the same those changes did as many of people have testified today had changed the age the number of years they had to do, the calculations, and most of those that were hired before 2011 had an understanding, verbal contract, of what they would receive from the retirement system.
So I'm asking that this committee submit this bill for consideration or to be added to the subcommittee for further consideration.
Thank you.
Are there any questions from the committee?
I don't see any, so thank you very much.
Thank you for your consideration.
Mr.
Cavanaugh, do you need to add anything?
I'm still Mark Kavanaugh from the retirement system.
This bill addresses the same issue we've been discussing in the broadest way by eliminating the tier system and restoring everyone who was subject to it, those transition rules, to the law as it existed on 7-1, prior to 7-1-11, which is for age 45, 20 years, and a 2.5 multiplier.
Consequently, it's the most expensive of the bills, unfortunately.
$6.5 million estimated increase in contributions for the state in fiscal year 26, $25.88 million for the political subdivisions.
That would be an annual cost going forward.
And it also would increase the actuarial accrued liabilities by 226 million dollars uh finally i'd say that each of these bills also has significant administrative challenges in i.t costs the i.t programming costs will range between 100 and000 for each of these bills, depending on which one makes it through the House.
In that regard, if any, these bills all try to do the same thing so only one of them can pass.
And it might be a combination or some variation of what we've discussed today.
And with that, I open it up for questions okay thank you are there any questions from the committee representative true thank you madam chair thank you for taking my question did you say this adds to the unfunded liability uh 226 million dollars yes okay that's that's if you were to terminally fund the increase in benefits that's how much you'd have to come up with today yes and if you could give me a definition again about terminal terminal funding means paying up front uh the cot the future cost of the increase in benefit as opposed to paying for it over time through annual increases in the contributions paid by the employers.
MS.
Instead of $6.5 million from the state every year from 26 ad infinitum, it would be, what, 100-something?
MR.
200.
MS.
226, I think, is it?
In the lump sum right now.
now.
Yeah, 226 would pay for it all up front.
And the employee contribution would be times 20?
At least 20, yeah.
Yeah.
does the um the largest bulk of group two works for the local municipalities so that's where it would hit hardest so this committee being a policy committee we could use one of the previous bills that we've kept to incorporate some of these thoughts into.
Certainly.
Okay, thank you.
And we do, if it's amended bill, we can do a new fiscal note worksheet.
And if you had two variations you wanna do, you could do two different amendments.
Yes.
And get comparative costs.
We might well want to do that.
Yeah.
You usually need at least a week turnaround on that with the actuaries.
But would it be fair to say that this bill is about the maximum we could expect for eliminating that transition period?
Yes, because it fully eliminates it altogether.
Okay, then.
The only thing more expensive would be to increase the benefits for new hires after 1-1-12.
Okay, well, we're not talking about that this week, maybe next week.
No.
Well, that's what it was when they were hired, so they weren't promised anything different.
Okay, so, well, that at least gives us a range of, we don't know exactly where our decisions would lay on that range we've got a range of costs mm-hmm thank you we'd also caution in terms of effective date we're undergoing a computer conversion it's a five-year process we go live with it next January and we run parallel starting in October so you can imagine trying to layer on the administrative reprogramming of both the old and the new system that had to be done we need significant lead time because our staff in our IT people in our outside IT vendors are already at full capacity dealing with our conversion okay well this we'll keep that in mind just need a little time thank you any other questions all right thank you for your testimony Thank you.
Claudia.
other questions all right thank you for your testimony thank you uh claudia person or something oh i'm sorry claudia excuse me buddy prescott so i just want to point a clarification i think he said that it was a verbal contract um actually the state retirement system used to send us every single year in the mail just like um i think he used to get from social security I THINK HE SAID THAT IT WAS A VERBAL CONTRACT.
ACTUALLY, THE STATE RETIREMENT SYSTEM USED TO SEND US EVERY SINGLE YEAR IN THE MAIL, JUST LIKE I THINK HE USED TO GET FROM SOCIAL SECURITY.
IT WAS AN EXPLANATION OF BENEFITS, JUST LIKE YOU USED TO GET FROM SOCIAL SECURITY, THAT IF YOU CONTINUED IN SERVICE, THIS WOULD BE YOUR BENEFIT AT THE END OF 20 YEARS.
THEY STOPPED DOING THAT AFTER THE CHANGES WERE MADE IN 2010.
SO IT WAS ACTUALLY A WRITTEN CONTRACT THAT WAS RENEGED UPON.
SO IT WAS JUST.
So it was just a point of clarification.
And then the other thing is as far as the monetary, currently 100% of those millions of dollars that you're talking about are being borne by, I think it's less than 2,000 first responders.
So 100% of those costs, and the number goes down every year because we're paying for it.
So that's all borne upon us.
These costs are all borne by the employer.
The employees pay a fixed percentage of their salary.
Yes, but we're talking about if they were to put our benefits back to what they were, then that would change the dynamics of it.
But you would not, as employees, you would not have to make any further contributions because none of these affect what your contribution is.
All right, that's true, but it would also go into our taxes.
So we currently do pay for it.
That's true.
We all still pay for it.
Agreed.
Any questions or Mr.
Scott?
All right.
Thank you for the information.
Thanks.
Does anyone else wish to testify on House Bill 579?
All right.
Seeing not.
Oh, please introduce yourself and, uh, thank you.
all right seeing not oh please introduce yourself and uh thank you thank you madam chair my name is john levasseur uh i got hired in 2003 um in corrections uh i did four more years in a smaller police department and then transferred to Manchester Police Department.
In 2011, when that bill passed, I had nine years on.
So guys working next to me.
With 10 years, had a much larger pension for what they did.
And me working side by side with them, I got a much reduced rate.
I find it very unfair.
I signed a contract.
That was a contract that I had for retirement.
And I'm looking for this state to back us up here and do the right thing because it was wrong.
Now, I get it.
Some people don't like pensions.
Some people have different views.
But that's what I signed up for.
And in nine years on the job, I only had so much time to recoup from my future retirement because this job is not meant to do for 30 years.
It's not.
Okay?
20 years.
That's what this job asked of me.
I came to calls, domestics, disputes, stabbing, suicides, you name it.
It's not an easy job.
And when that happened, that just took my soul from me.
I'm currently retiring at 42 years old.
I'm off this job.
I'm done.
Absolutely cooked.
And I'm leaving early and I'm freezing it.
I'm not sticking around.
I'm not waiting for this bill, but I am supporting my local, brothers and sisters behind here because it was wrong what happened.
You guys really need to help us out here and step up and do the right thing.
We had a contract.
Please back this up and fight for us just this because it's the right thing to do.
That's what I ask of you.
Okay?
Thank you for your testimony.
I appreciate it.
Thank you.
I don't see any questions, so thank you very much.
Thank you very much.
Emmett Mackin.
Good afternoon.
Sergeant Emmett Mackin of Manchester Police here representing myself, however.
I wasn't really going to say anything, but I'm fearing I may not have an opportunity before somebody looks at these bills, so I just wanted to get a few things out there.
this is a retention issue hands down I came here from out of state I was NYPD officer for five years when I came to the state the number one thing I looked at was a pension system there's no other thing to look at.
I left a place of good benefits and a good pension.
And I wasn't going to come here for a lesser benefit or a lesser pension, which is what happened when I had about seven years here and things got changed.
So if you don't think that this is a word of mouth thing that goes around, there's a whole unwritten world out here with cops, right?
You don't think I'd go to Massachusetts tomorrow if they gave me a better deal than I have right now in Manchester.
You better believe I would.
There's no reason to.
Why would I not go somewhere better for a payday?
We already don't have health care.
There's already a bunch of things that I accepted when I came here that it was not going to get.
And I made an informed decision when I did come here.
And then to have six, seven years on the job and have this rug pulled out from under your feet, it's a trust issue with people.
I've had guys that I know that were looking to come here when they hear that.
Understandably, they're like, I'm not rolling the dice.
What if it gets worse six years after I'm there, right?
It just, it's unprecedented.
I don't know of any other state that did things the way they did it here, right?
So there's a chance to correct some of these issues, restore some trust here, you know?
There's another bill downstairs right now that's affecting us.
There's bills coming up all the time, right?
There's a profession under the gun half the time, I think.
Something happens in California, right?
We hear about it here, right?
So we have an extremely professional police and fire and EMS and everything in the state.
I was blown away by how professional and educated and well-trained everybody was when I got here.
I don't want to lose that.
I'm going to have to work with these people, right?
I want the best coming here.
I want to continue to have the best.
I have a family here.
I want my children to be protected and served by the best people.
I don't want to lose them to Massachusetts or Maine or New York or California or wherever, you know, because that's what's going to happen.
That's what's happening now.
You never saw anybody leave these jobs early, ever.
I never heard of it.
I never heard of a cop doing 17 years and pulling the plug in my life.
You know, I mean, it just never happened before.
It's happening here in droves.
I've never seen it before.
And there's a reason for that.
There's only one reason for that.
It's the retirement system.
It's hands down.
You know, you can deal with all the other pressures.
We deal with it every day.
We try to help each other out.
But this is the one thing you can't, we have no control over, right?
You guys do.
So please help us out.
Thank you.
If you have any questions or.
Thank you for your testimony.
I don't see any questions.
Oh, it's a representative of Gerhard.
Thank you, Madam Chair.
Just a quick question for you.
What is the difference in pay we're talking about here for the people that were pre-11 and post-?
What do you mean?
Like percentage maybe?
Yeah, like what's the total?
It's a significant number.
It would be different for everybody.
I wouldn't have those numbers off the top of my head.
I had no idea.
If you're a representative Gerhard, it would, if you're getting a factor of two instead of two and a half, you're getting 80% of the pension for the same years worked in the same final set.
20% reduction.
You mean if you went somewhere else?
No, no, no.
Just the difference in between you saying the guy next to you, the head, was vested and wasn't.
I don't know what the numbers are.
He could have 20% more than you would do for the same final pay.
Oh, that wasn't i'm just i don't know what the numbers are you could have 20 more than you 20 for the same final pay oh yeah that wasn't me said that but yeah i guess so yeah okay i just didn't know what the number thank you if it was a dollar you don't think i'd be upset right but it's it's it's not a dollar you know i mean it's a significant number but like i said a ton of us came in here under one thing why why would i come here you know what i mean so and and talking to people and trying to recruit people here it's a big word of mouth thing i've had plenty of guys looking to come up here that saves this state or any agency a ton of money you know they can go to an abbreviated academy get somebody with a lot of time on that's all trained up has all these certificates that we'd pay thousands for that we don't have to.
And they're like, well, I'm not going to go there.
That makes no sense.
And you're losing the guy who does have all that experience.
He's leaving early, right?
You know, like these are people I would have stuck around.
I mean, you're throwing money, you're flushing it away.
Like you're saving it in these calculations.
I get it.
At the end, right?
Like, we've already heard.
But how much are we losing thousands before that?
Right?
The guy with 9, 10 years on is like, he looks at it.
Well, I got hired when I was 21.
Now that I'm 30, it's just not worth it to stay.
And they're going to the private sector.
Like I said, I don't ever remember that happening.
I've been a cop for 23 years.
I've never heard of him before the last, like, five or six years.
I see it happening a lot.
It's just not something that ever happened.
And I think it's a tragedy to let it, when it can be corrected.
Thank you.
Representative Shewitt.
Thank you, Madam Chair.
Just, I think I understood correctly what you said.
You were working for NYPD and you were speaking with other officers from different states.
And what you heard about New Hampshire is what enticed you to come here and seek employment.
Is that true?
Yes.
At the time.
now it's having the opposite effect it it looks attractive until they start talking to us and then like well that's too much of a gamble why why bother yeah thank you very much for your testimony thank you very much does anyone else wish to testify on house bill 579 yes please good afternoon madam chair committee members thank you for your time please introduce yourself yes ma'am uh gary burke i work at the department of corrections state president concord i'm a captain there i'm also the vice president or acting vice acting of our union.
I was listening to a lot of the bills today.
I'm hoping that you will take the time and to consider some type of change.
I started in 10-1 of 04.
I did know Officer LeVassar, Manchester PD, who's friends with one of my friends, Michael Valle, who's still at Manchester PD.
We started here with a contract.
We went in, we had a hiring process.
We signed, they told us what our benefits were.
We would see that sheet every year.
This has created a massive problem.
It has created a trust issue between the employees and the state of who we work for.
People don't believe that the benefits will be restored.
I was also affected by the layoffs at the facility in 2008 in Laconia, which also definitely hurt the Department of Corrections because we were unable to pull from the counties or the municipalities to come there.
There's been a steady erosion of benefits since.
The overtime that we have to do due to the lack of staffing there, minimum, most staff would average about 24 hours of overtime a week at the Department of Corrections currently.
So when I do 22 years, because under this, it put me to a tiered system at an average of just 20 hours a week, I would have to do 33, I'll have 33 years of service when I go in an environment that is not suited for most individuals with what we deal with on a day from riots, disturbances, several individuals with mental health issues there, placing people in proactive restraint chairs.
I'll wind up with 22 years of service as it stays now, but I'll actually have 36.5 years when you count the overtime hours that I have to do.
I had a contract with the state and I would just ask that the state honors that contract with everybody else, including myself.
Recruitment and retention's hurt.
We just lost five supervisors last year with 120 years total of state service.
We did replace those people, people promoted.
That total years of service for those people that replace them is 13 years of service.
So if you could think about that at any of the jobs you've had, when you take those years and you replace them with somebody new, the years, the experiences, what they've seen, and the potential for the issues that that can cause in the work environment is great.
I know that people have said that we had a minimum 20% reduction of pay for the benefits, madam, that you just said, but also the other thing too is in the system, it's also an increase of years as well, right?
I went from 20 years to 22.
So when you look at what we do in group two, it doesn't matter if you're in firefighting, if you're in police, if you're in corrections, you look at, it's also about weighing the quality of life.
So the idea of coming here, when I started, my father worked for the federal government for 41 years.
So I think I was kind of born or indoctrinated to be a career guy.
So what enticed me was the benefits.
You give 20 years of state service, you work hard, and there was a defined pension that you would get when you left.
After being there for, you know, seven years, they just said, sorry, well, that went away.
And it's also the quality of life.
I think one thing that people haven't mentioned is not only does it affect me, but it affects my family, it affects my children.
Because when you work in these jobs, you answer that bell 24 seven, you represent where you work, we get forced, which basically means I don't have the opportunity to sign up, I may have plans at home, and I'm told that I have to stay.
So your family makes that commitment to you as well.
It's not just you by yourself.
There is a lot of stress.
I know a group that I represent, One Voice United, we work with mental health and corrections.
The average life expectancy of an officer in corrections is 59 years versus 75 for everybody else.
So I just would like the members here today to consider what we're really giving up in corrections and law enforcement in general when we're doing these jobs.
I know that there are other bills here today, and I do agree that something should be done.
And whether it's a combination of what we do, I know that there was another House bill today relative to physical fitness standards.
And I think it's, you know, that's tough, too, because, again, you're also looking, we're there for 16 hours a day.
We're ordering out every night.
It's not exactly easy to plan our life there.
And again, thank you for your time, but this was just a contract that we had.
And I would just like to state to honor their word because I've honored my word for the last 18 and a half years as a state employee, moving through the ranks, promoting people, recruiting people, people trying to retain it's a hard sell to what we have right now to try to pull people in and try to convince people to stay because there isn't any trust so as soon as people can pull the plug they do because they're worried that maybe the state will come out and tell them that you have more years of service to do or there's even a greater reduction of benefits so please help us out and consider one of these bills to push forward i'll take any questions and thank you for your time.
Thank you for your testimony.
Questions?
Okay.
Yes.
Representative Garrett.
Thank you, Madam Chair.
I hear a contract being thrown around multiple times.
So a contract is a legal document.
Has this been brought through the courts?
I don't know.
I'm just curious.
No, it has not.
It has not been brought through the courts.
Okay.
okay do you have any plan can i follow up i i'm not sure he was the best person to ask but you can ask well i mean you're a member of a major organization uh president acting president have you guys have plans to bring said contract up for discussion in judiciary so years ago sir we were told that this was brought up and we tried to change that and that the court system had ruled that this was not a actual contract um so so it was it was unsuccessful that was kind of the first thing to do is to say hey look we signed this we signed our hiring papers we went through training went through orientation let's honor this but the thought process from other people was that that was not the case so we were not successful okay questions thank you for your testimony and for your service does anyone else wish to testify on house bill 579 okay seeing none i will close the public hearing and without objection go into executive session representative Grota I do I have a motion of ITL for House Bill 540 579 is there a second okay I'll second it again and you wish to speak to your motion do.
And I don't want anyone in this room to think that I don't support what you're saying.
I'm not sympathetic to it.
And I'm deeply touched by the things that I've heard.
I've been on this committee for my third term, and this is something that's come up every single time and the thing that concerns me the most is the loss of trust that is a significant thing to me because it takes so long to build trust and it takes so long to rebuild it after you've lost it.
I also want you to know that the subcommittee is open to the public so that we have two bills to work with.
We have House Bill 436 and House Bill 449, which is why I don't think we need this other bill.
So I encourage you to come to those subcommittee meetings because they are public and make sure that your voice is heard.
I will be there.
I'm not on the subcommittee, but I will be there.
So because this bill is similar to the other bills, and I think that we can incorporate these concepts in another bill if we so choose, I make this motion of ITL.
I hope the committee will support me.
Yes, and I second it for the same reason as House Bill 525.
They're too similar.
They all address the same problem in very much the same way, and we'll have to consider which of these concepts we'll go forward with.
Any other comments, questions from the committee?
All right.
Seeing none, the motion is inexpedient to legislate on House Bill 579, and the clerk can call the roll.
Representative Bailey.
Yes.
Representative True.
Representative Dolan.
Yes.
Representative Hebert.
Representative Gerhard.
Yes.
The clerk votes yes representative grotta yes representative schuitt yes representative wilhelm yes representative davis yes representative fitzpatrick yes Yes.
And the chair?
Yes.
We have a vote 12-A, 0-Nay.
All right.
Is there any objection?
At a vote of 12-0, the motion passes.
Is there any objection to consent?
All right.
Seeing none, we'll put this on consent.
And at your earliest convenience.
Madam Chair,'m chair when is you say the subcommittee for this will be thursday uh if representative simon doesn't schedule something else sooner we will have definitely have a meeting on thursday after the session or in the afternoon whichever comes first or last madam chair um as representative groda sort of invited folks to sit in can you tell them how they can find out when that would be scheduled the uh yes the meeting on thursday will be in the house calendar and it will be in this room um the if there's any previous meeting it will be announced the easiest way to find out would be to look up house bill uh 436 or 449 and look in the docket and that will WILL TELL YOU IF THERE IS AN EXTRA SUBCOMMITTEE MEETING SCHEDULED AND IF SO WHERE AND WHEN.
REPRESENTATIVE TRUE.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
I BELIEVE MY UNDERSTANDING WAS AT OUR LAST SUBCOMMITTEE MEETING WE WERE GOING TO MEET AT 9 O'CLOCK NEXT WEDNESDAY.
I DON'T KNOW IF THAT WAS WRITTEN IN STONE OR Well, these bills...
our last subcommittee meeting we were going to meet at nine o'clock next wednesday i don't know if that was written in stone or well these bills hadn't been assigned to the subcommittee at that point so uh if so that'll be that should be in the calendar already all right and thank you all for attending and thank you for all the information you brought.
We are finished for the day.